Which wells in forests dense and deep,
she you hide within the shallows,
resides in the forgotten key,
and don't be fooled to think that she
will not give you any fright for she may
very well be hiding right there in plain
sight.
Yes.
Be aware of this creature who does dwell
when lovely weeds for she will put a
spell on you.
Crop to mark her devilish deeds for she
is the uncanny nature,
which she calls her home the storm,
the accident,
the unending frost.
She put four from atop her from.
It's been a long winter.
She's the baron boom,
the miscarriage,
the infertility of the land.
She said,
dragon of chaos.
Who Does give death?
A helping hand.
Both ball drop ball.
We were of the which for a lawyer is
strong,
for she taps into your desires.
When your cravings are wrong,
she whispers or conservations from
across the pond,
from over.
Oh Lord.
And that will give you all you want to
not wish to on an eternal love.
Maternal warmth,
heat,
not these words for it'll grasp you
under a spell for you are surely to
drown in your family as well.
Be Aware of the witch who devours are
young with talks of sweets and bliss.
Oh yes.
In the Candy House for trap is Sprung.
Come,
come little children and that will give
you all you want to stay with me here to
get her with your loving arms habit.
Something hot to drink.
Yes,
please.
Beware of the which now for she will
play her trick,
twisting and turning.
She'll close the door and before you
know it,
your inner stew with a carrot and a
stick.
She hates what you are and what she is
not so devour.
Shoe hold and leaves,
nothing drawn for the which is the
mother who wishes to hold onto her
throne,
and so she prays and our young in order
to hide her inner crone
younger,
she's the healer who breeds illness.
The teacher who spreads lies the seer
who relishes in the chaos she sees
unfold in front of her eyes.
Yes,
beware of the which now,
but do not confuse her with our twin for
even though she may be as old as in
touch with nature as Erkin,
she will provide us with health and good
spirits which will guide you from
within.
She's wise upon our years,
a teacher through and through.
She will know what you need when you do
happen to be feeling.
How do you get the
job done?
You can save yourselves.
If you tell me who it was
you were of the which yes,
but likewise.
Beware of those who seek to twist and
turn to truth.
All the same.
They dressed me up like this.
Point their fingers here and there and
do dare to exclaim buy we bought back
in which he,
which is what you are for you know,
to devil's ways.
Last night you took my husband's heart
and for debt you'll be set.
Ablaze
is those who claim to know,
to which and who see her whenever they
roam or to self assured and blind to see
that she lives inside their home.
For beware of the which of your own
nature,
the witch who still haunts your dreams
per perhaps it is you who seeks to twist
and turn in order to make nothing as it
seems
you alright?
Oh,
you might be aware of your resentments,
your alliance,
and who you curse of what you hold back
and what you might crave for.
Perhaps your crusade will lead you round
and round as it is yourself.
Who you are,
to brave
compose it.
So whatever you may hear or whatever you
may read,
look out for the which for she will have
what you need.
She will set things in motion.
She will stirred the pot for revenge.
Her dreadful appearance lies the power
to break you're in or not.
And although knowledge of this creature
will no doubt make you twitch,
one must never forget to be aware of the
which.